now without a doubt no shortage of
corruption in the swamp in DC but
perhaps the single most dishonest the
most untrustworthy unethical person in
our nation's capital might be that guy
the compromised corrupt congenital liar
Adam Schiff now recently Shipp published
phone records from the president's
attorneys investigative reporter John
Solomon and his Republican colleague
congressman Devin Nunez that means the
corrupt cowardly compromise Schiff was
spying on a member of Congress and a
reporter Free Press and the president's
personal attorneys and his Kimberly
Strasse pointed out in the Wall Street
Journal mr. Schiff has trampled law and
responsibilities of nothing else Schiff
claims the distinction of being the
first congressman to use his official
powers to spy on a fellow member and
published the details now congressman
Nunez is way his legal options
rightfully so here with reaction
former Florida Attorney General Pam
Bondi Florida congressman Matt gates Pam
will go to you and your legal expertise
he got the phone records from what the
phone company is spying a member on the
president's lawyer seriously and to
tread very carefully write
attorney-client privilege of what he's
doing and you know that's why today in
the White House we wrote a letter Patsy
bologna wrote a letter to Natalie saying
that Nancy Pelosi is already
predetermined guilt she's ordered them
to go ahead with articles of impeachment
so why in the world would we participate
in any of this sham they need to drop it
now but if they don't we wrote in our
letter you know what if you don't do it
fast get it to the Senate where we can
have a fair trial because you know who
we want to call Adam Schiff we want to
call the whistleblower and we want to
call hunter Biden and don't you find it
interesting Sean that Adam Schiff won't
even be presenting his report he's
having the lawyer the counsel do it
instead of him wonder why he doesn't
want to testify ken starr presented his
report but Adam Schiff sure doesn't want
to present his but if this goes to the
Senate shouldn't ever go there we want
to hear from Adam chef Matt Gaetz
this is very disturbing to me the
president's lawyer a fellow member of
Congress and a reporter that would and
and the folk um but he's cooperated I
have a problem with all of that do you
think there's a problem
I do Sean it was just yesterday though
that you and I were speaking about our
mutual love for the people of Pensacola
and I just wanted to say that our hearts
are breaking now as our service members
are dealing with this tragic act of
violence that occurred in my community a
community by the way let me let me
answer those remarks congressman and I
saw your tweet earlier today I thought I
love the people of Pensacola you know
how I feel about Pensacola you they love
you too and when I compared the
patriotism and bravery of my
constituents with just the savagery of
Washington DC right now the contrast
could not be more stark Adam Schiff is
one of the lowest integrity people that
I have ever seen in public life and if
he really stands behind these false
allegations he should at least have the
guts to show up and defend them himself
but instead he's sending his lawyers
he's sending his staff when did the
actual members of Congress get dealt out
of the critical work that is before us I
think it's because Adam Schiff knows
that as a consequence of his lies as a
consequence of conducting most of this
in the bunker of the basement of the
Capitol
he has no credibility so Democrats are
looking for maybe a lawyer or a staff
member with more credibility than Schiff
when it comes to these phone records
you're right there is a trampling of
Rights here that goes far beyond the
Trump presidency it speaks to our
separation of powers our civil liberties
and Democrats used to claim they were
the party of civil liberties I guess
that was until Donald Trump got elected
because they will do anything to tear
apart this great president